hey wassup Samuel Leeds listen on this
video I'm just gonna so I'm just going
to say as it is I'm going to say some
some stuff that I've been advised not to
say I'm gonna say some stuff that's
gonna last time I said this it was
already in the video game taken down
very very very quickly and it caused a
bit of a crash but listen right now
we're in lockdown right now people are
worried people are scared listen what
does warren buffett say what does Robert
Kiyosaki say what do the guys say they
say when everybody's scared that's when
you should be greedy
so he's freaking my brains out won't
seem so many professional property
investors that are scared right now who
should not be scared when people are
scared this is where you should be being
greedy
right now is an absolutely crazy
epidemic going on but you know what's
happening people are selling their
houses off twenty thirty forty percent
below market value I secured very very
recently drawing lockdown from my house
I secured a lease option agreement
I've been packaging and selling deals
people in China are dumping money into
the UK right now cash banks aren't
lending but the banks have got more
money than I've had in absolute years
the interest rates are lower than
they've been in hundreds of years and
when the banks have got no money that's
when credit crunch has happened right
now the banks have got money listen man
honestly I understood home I'm not
enjoying meals to go home but I taste
something I'm making money I'm doing
deals I'm documenting it so here's what
I want to say which is absolutely crazy
I can't run crash courses right now I
can't run events right now my training
the training that I love doing has had
to stop my winners Wednesday students
that I had lined up until June I can't
meet them I can't record with them and
normally what happens is people come to
the crash course and then they go into
the deal finding extravaganza they do
never use your own money again they pay
thousands of pounds for my training
programs and that is what then makes
them financially free it just is so I'm
going to do something insane right now
and that's this crash course
property investors crash course I put
the crash course on line I put it online
about two weeks ago and so many people
went on the website it crashed I closed
it off the deal finding extravaganza
three thousand pound program do it
doesn't pan hundreds and hundreds of
people have paid three thousand pounds
of
finding extravaganza I put that online
995 never use your own money again
program never use your own money again
talking about lease option agreement
specifically lease option agreements
right now are a really really really
powerful weapon never use your own money
again program three thousand pound
program nine ninety five online the
whole program its online right now so
here's one wanna do crash course
advanced training never use Roman again
deal finding a Stravaganza I'm making it
available this is the thing again
trouble with this is the thing that
brings crashes on the websites all those
training programs the advanced training
plus some coaching right now those that
register right now is going to be one
pound one friggin pound so one pound you
get access to the online property
investors crash course you get access to
the deal finding extravaganza hundreds
of people have paid thousands of pounds
for the training you get access to the
never use your own money again program
all for one pound two weeks
- absolutely consume the content and go
crazy over those two weeks while you do
the training I will also be there to
coach you we're going to be doing a
webinar every Wednesday so for the next
two Wednesdays for the pound I'll coach
you answer questions that you've got
you'll join the samuel 365 community
after few weeks if you want to stick
around you want to continue doing more
training you want to continue joining
the webinars 95 pounds per month it
makes me laugh that I'm even saying this
because it's insane but here's my
absolute mission it's not to make loads
of money my absolute mission is that
have ended financial independence for my
family and to help other people do the
same thing right now I know people are
struggling during lockdown people are
losing their jobs people haven't got
money people are struggling
I want leech my training to be
accessible to people I know people
haven't got thousands of pounds right
now to spend on training I know people
right now can't physically come to an
event that's what I'm saying one plan
training get to talk to me do some Q&A s
do it with the link below right now
because I taste something the websites
gonna crash again when it does what
we're gonna do as soon as he starts
going slow is booked we're gonna have to
turn it off last time I was getting
absolutely harassed for days hundreds of
people saying why have you turned it off
why we turned it off I can't do it I
can't do it I wanna pay my bow man I
wanna be my pal man and they couldn't
because I had to close you so if you're
watching this video
now click on the link below pay your
pound start the training let's do this
let's build financial independence for
our families and let's make the most of
this of this situation right now rather
than bitching and moaning and making
excuses what everyone's scared we should
as far as businesspeople are concerned
this is when we need to go in I made
most of my money get the best deals that
I've done just after the 2008 recession
that's when I went in and got the best
deals right now the best deals are
happening but you need to know what to
do
one pound to click my link let's do this